tomorrow morning is the big day the
annual fundraiser for the little miss
hannah foundation it's at cornerstone
park in henderson great news you can
still register for the race just be
there tomorrow at 8 a.m sharp before the
race kicks off at 8 45. the vegas cares
about rare event is scheduled to happen
in february to coincide with world rare
disease month raising awareness about
the millions of adults and children
affected by a rare disease now more than
ever our local kids affected by rare
diseases need our help and this event
has historically been the largest
fundraising event each and every year
once you're introduced to a child of
special needs or a rare disease or you
know medically complex it really touches
your heart in a good way that you want
to do more to help you want to give back
in some way and i think that's a really
great connection that that all of us
have here in the community
your participation in the 5k or the one
mile run translates to much needed
funding to let the little miss hannah
foundation continue to provide medical
and therapy equipment as well as
educational scholarship and family
support to all those families that need
that help across southern nevada